around 5,000 Islamic state fighters
positioned along Afghanistan's remote
border region with Central Asian
Republics according to the head of the
Russian Federal Security Services let's
look at the ramifications of that
bringing our correspondent eoh down off
you go hey there
so the FSB shedding more light on the
details of these fighters and where they
are and what they may be planned to do
well indeed Kevin just a little bit
context first the FSB is arguably the
most outspoken security service of
Russia and it is this behemoth of
collecting counterterrorism data and
well according to their ahead Alexander
bortnikov now a branch of Islamic state
was so-called Vilayet Horus on an
extremist group that pledged allegiance
to the notorious Islamic terrorist
organization apparently they have sent
thousands really thousands of their
members to Afghanistan and already
restless and restless country have a
listen we're especially concerned over
terrorist groups transfer to northern
Afghan provinces that border with CIS
countries one of the RS branches has
already deployed around 5,000 builders
their CIS citizens who have fought in
Syria account for a great part of these
militants and well Afghanistan is far
from the only hotspot on the Islamic
terrorism heatmap for instance according
to the information in possession of the
FSB such regions as North Africa and
Asia have become places where Islamic
terrorists have been steadily gaining
foothold and now the following piece of
information revealed by bortnikov makes
things even more concerning apparently
terrorists have developed and obtained
all means necessary to produce chemical
weapons and carry out chemical attacks
we have obtained reliable data providing
that bandits are testing new means and
methods of conducting subversive
activities criminals have materials
technologies and infrastructure for
creating chemical weapons and biotoxins
they use unmanned aircraft in order to
deliver projectiles and while terrorism
activities there
not limited to the well physical warfare
if I may say so for instance according
to bortnikov Islamic state has been
bolstering its so-called cyber
departments they have been expanding
their ability to bring down the cyber
infrastructure of official bodies and
apparently even government's they have
been expanding their abilities
equipment-wise
modernizing these cyber departments
again if I may call them this way also
Islamic state has been historically
notorious for the quality and quantity
of their propaganda and now especially
with Islamic state seems well holding no
ground they have moved their operations
to the darker corners of the internet
they have been spreading propaganda and
misinformation even more actively than
before according to the FSB in a bit of
course to gain new followers new
sympathizers new recruits with well
potential to turn them late into active
terror cells
you